the next speaker
was a member of a step dance team in
college
please everyone welcome benji
i'm really excited to uh be here today
to talk about this topic um over the pa
of course of the past two or three days
if you've attended the workshops uh
we've learned some really amazing
techniques from some of the most
talented people in the our community and
that's really awesome um but here what i
want to do is do though is take a step
back from the technical aspects of our
job and focus on the human interpersonal
aspect um and that's because no matter
how awesome our products and insights
are they won't be a thing if our
non-technical colleagues and clients uh
can't understand them
so to many of our non-technical
colleagues what we do is a complete
mystery um and i've found that it
fosters a strange mindset
data science seems to be able to be to
do both everything and nothing at the
same time
so for certain problems people think
they can do everything they think that
we're magicians or super talented
athletes that can overcome any obstacle
they think there's some off the shelf
deep learning and it's it's always deep
learning way to predict any fluctuation
to classify any document and reduce
human work time by 90 percent
and
while it might be nice to be thought of
this way having these that kind of
expectations is a really big problem
that's because these expectations are
impossible to me and if we can't meet
and achieve them our work is deemed a
failure
on the other hand there are many who
think data science can do nothing and
think that their area of expertise their
workflow is so innately human it
requires so much complicated thinking
that no amount of technology can help
repeatable script instead of hand jam
spreadsheet an app some basic filtering
all of these are too simple for this
bespoke indescribable work
so we all know that the truth lies
somewhere in the middle um there's
hardly any human-centric effort that
can't be aided with technology
can it solve all our problems of course
not can it help things along in ways
both large and small certainly
so the problem we find ourselves in is a
problem of communication
how can we tell our clients and
colleagues what we can do to help while
recognizing and respecting their
capabilities and limitations
beyond telling how do we actually
integrate our findings and products into
their solutions
in the government this can be a
particular challenge
a lot of policy makers tend to be old
school much of the work is people driven
there are countless committees and
hierarchies new ideas need to go through
before they can be implemented
at every step there's someone who can
stymie our efforts that's why it's so
important for all data scientists to be
good communicators but especially those
of us who work in government and who are
trying to enact positive change
all right so so why should you listen to
me about this um i've worked in the
federal space specifically the dod and
intelligence community for over a decade
as both a civilian and a contractor i've
had the opportunity to support
operational and being operational and
policy roles and support a variety of
missions including counter-terrorism and
counter proliferation as well as
supporting supply chain risk management
like i am now
i.t integration
training and even diversity equity
inclusion initiatives um and all my
stops along the way i've had a lot of
communication failures and some
successes so let's look at one of each
one failure and one success and uh well
we can what we can learn from them
so let's start with an example from
early in my career when i was supporting
the diversity inclusion section of the
human resources directorate of a federal
law enforcement agency
at this time and i'm sure still
leadership was very concerned with the
feeling that minority employees were
receiving disproportionately low
performance assessments uh this led to
widespread resentment and distrust of
the process
but it was just a feeling they didn't
have any back data to back it up
um so when i heard about this in a
meeting with the chief
i immediately said i i can see if that's
true let me get to work
um i knew that we could test her
hypothesis that minority employees
receiving disproportionately low scores
through a chi-square test
and so when i give this talk to students
um i go into the details about how i got
the data and so on um but i'll cut to
the chase here uh these scores are not
due to random chats like p-value of
.0001
um and when i got this result i was
really stoked i had the data the chief
wanted and it confirmed her thinking um
i wrote up a report and i put a
presentation together instead of me to
talk to to talk to her
and it was a total dud i tried to
explain it but it just didn't land um
and she went back just to asking me for
the other regular reports i was giving
her
um so
you know why why did it fail um
it took me a long time um and some good
reflection to to come to this but what
i've what i've
settled on was that i just told her i
was going to solve it i didn't actually
talk to her about the results and what
they would actually look like so when i
showed up to her with a p-value there
was nothing for she didn't know what to
do with it
um
i never asked her how she was actually
going to use this information like where
what she was going to do with the
results of of this analysis and i made
it about me it was just a stats report
not part of an integrated solution my
customer could actually use
um so the bottom line for this is that
if your final deliverables of p-value it
probably isn't going to land
um okay so let's turn to another example
at a different agency where i did the
opposite where i was successful
in delivering a data science insight
using uh better communication
and interestingly this problem was
was actually more complicated and had a
more complex solution
and this time the key of success was
working with the clients to understand
their process how it would be used and
how data science could help
so every year this agency would devote a
large percentage of its budget to grants
for r d
but previous year's grants proposals
were kept in a folder as word documents
with just alphanumeric codes as the
names of the as the names of the files
so
basically it was impossible beyond
remembering from past years if a new if
a new proposal was like any formal
proposals
they had no way of comparing past
proposals to new ones no way of knowing
if they had awarded something similar in
the past and if it was a success or
failure or if they had an award or if
they hadn't awarded something similar in
the past how was the new proposal
different how might it actually change
things
so the solution we came up with was to
read all the reports in and use drvec to
take a current grant and compare it to
all previous years grants and get the
top and most similar grants so to to be
fair this we didn't use r for this but
we made a shiny app they use the output
so that's how that's how i'm justifying
using this example here um
so the
it and what was
what was really successful about this is
that the clients actually use the
results of this in the grant awarding
process
um
so why was this successful um
i explained from the very beginning what
the outcome was going to be and how it
could be used
i explained using the minimum necessary
info so like i wasn't talking to them
about like skip gram or bag of words or
things like that but i didn't dumb it
down either um i explained to them that
how what we were doing wasn't magic it
was math um cleverly applied to and that
the technique had been in use now for
for a while
um
and they actually started using the
results of this system in the grant
awarding process now to be fair the
client didn't actually use the app
themselves we did um and i'm sure a lot
of you who have worked in government
space are used to setting up um with
like bi tools like tableau or other
things like that where your end customer
still ends up having you print out the
reports for them to read
um
all right so
what are like the basic
the do's and don'ts then of
communicating data science findings to
to non-experts
um
number one
is understanding your end user so what
are their strengths and weaknesses how
will they use what what you're giving
them
i think if you compare the two case
studies that i've talked about so far
today um
you see that in in one there wasn't
really much of an effort to understand
the process or the end user and the
other there was a lot of care and effort
and that goes a long way in actually
being able to affect change and
get what you're producing into action
um
really important especially in
government is understanding your end
user's boss
this this is so essential because almost
every decision
will require approval or at least
consensus from multiple people and
multiple levels of authority so it's not
just enough to understand your your end
user you need to understand the their
ecosystem if you want your product to be
successful or your insight to be heard
so
number three is don't make it about you
so don't do what you want to do do what
your customer needs does that means
sometimes using a less sexy approach so
you can explain it for sure um
even in the first first circumstance i
talked about today something pretty
basic in our minds wasn't able wasn't
able to land and that's really because i
made that process about me and not about
how my customer could actually use
something
so four be humble
you can only do so much no matter how
smart and talented you are you're part
of a large organization and you have to
understand understand that so we're not
going to change the world in a in a day
and we need to understand how we can
contribute
while staying staying
grounded
so five determine in advance how your
product will be used so this is this is
more tactical but totally vital um
before you get to work work with your
end user to see and deliver a product
that will be usable
ideally in the existing process so in
this case
whereas in the first
example
i did some analysis with no thought of
how the end user would actually apply it
in the second case
i spent a lot of time working with the
end users of
understanding the process and how the
analysis could actually be used
and i think that's why it was actually
successful
six uh bring them along your journey um
and i think what what
what i mean by saying this is keep
people informed as you move along um
this lets your initiative your
insight your product become something
they feel ownership in
and that will help lead to its adoption
and lead to their greater understanding
and last seven is be prepared to defend
your work so take your work seriously
and your customers will too
uh even though this should be a
user-centric process that doesn't mean
they're calling all the shots so
you're the expert you're the expert here
you need to work to understand their
process but
keep in mind who you who you are and
your talents and skill sets
so that's my uh that's my talk thank you
very much and uh please feel free to get
in touch with me to talk about
this type of work in the government
space